la liste des souhaits est longue pour le
développement des régions prolongement
de l'a 9 prolongement de l'a 40
construction de nouveaux ponts de
nouveaux échangeurs
ce sont des demandes qui sont légitimes
notamment pour favoriser l'accès à de
nouveaux investissements au
développement régional mais aussi pour
contrer la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
un souhait qui n'a toujours pas été
exaucé ici dans le bas saint laurent
bienvenue au bout de l'autoroute 20 à
notre dame des neiges ici l'a20 s'arrête
il faut emprunter une petite route qui
mène à la 132 c'est la seule voie
routière qui fait le lien entre la
région de rimouski et la gaspésie
et cela pose de sérieux problèmes en cas
d'accident tout est paralysé en cas de
tempête de neige c'est la même chose
aucune autre issue d'ailleurs l'hiver
dernier toute la région a été
complètement coupée du monde pendant une
centaine d'heures suffisamment pour
empêcher l'approvisionnement de
certaines épiceries et de bloquer
l'accès au service des ambulanciers et
des pompiers et sur site unique voie
routière il faut rouler à 50 kilomètres
à l'heure sur certaines portions et même
parfois il faut s'arrêter parce qu'il ya
un passage pour piétons afin de
faciliter l'accès aux commerces et
d'ailleurs dans les prochaines semaines
on va même y installer des feux de
signalisation
certains vous diront qu'il n'y a pas de
quoi en faire un fromage mais pour les
élus c'est une aberration qui existe
depuis trop longtemps
il faudrait donc construire un nouveau
tronçon d'autoroute d'une cinquantaine
de kilomètres et un pont au dessus de la
rivière trois pistoles coût total
certains avancent le chiffre de 900
millions de dollars mais pour obtenir un
prolongement d'autoroute un échangeur ou
un pont il faut que le projet soit
inscrit dans le fameux pq hisser dans ce
cadre précis que seront investis d'ici
2028 20 milliards de dollars
malheureusement pour le
bas-saint-laurent le prolongement de
l'autoroute 20 a été retiré de la liste
des priorités en 2015
au fait la 20 à une autre fin ici à ce
rond point puisque à l'autre bout de la
route 132 priorité d'une autre époque
il y à un autre tronçon qui étaient
construits entre le big et mont-joli et
donc certains rêvent que peut-être un
jour ils arriveront à joindre les deux
bouts de l'autoroute 20